I want to be crystal clear here I don't  support any kind of sex work I'm  actually very against only fans and very  against prostitution and I'm also very  against a webcam business I think that  it's very degrading to women I think  it's toxic I think it's unhealthy  mentally for women and I think that  women should preserve their value women  lose value by showing their bodies off  like that to the entire world especially  when there's a sexual transaction when  there's money I don't like it I think  it's degrading to women and I'm against  it however just because I think it's  unethical doesn't mean that it's illegal  and somebody should be put in jail for  this what Andrew chooses to do is his  business it's none of my business each  to their own as well as far as I know  all the women consent to this so as long  as it's consensual nothing really here  is illegal